this is joe Matarese I got problems and
they need fixing
I look right all right you're gonna have
to go through hell worse than any
nightmare you have a dream if I can
change and you can change
you're listening to fixing Joe every
week I'm gonna bring my real life
problems with this podcast my friends my
listeners my guests my family they're
all gonna help me and trust me i needed
i got tons of problems I'm anxious I
have OCD I have a.d.d narcissistic I'm
insecure I got anger out the ass and all
these things come together to ruin my
life all the time I'm hoping the show
can help you're listening to fixing Joe
let's thank wild fire radio.com right at
the top here they make me go live every
week and we're doing another one live
tomorrow night so let's start with that
plug if you want to listen to me again
tomorrow night should be really exciting
because i will be doing the podcast from
the stress factory in new brunswick new
jersey at eight-thirty p.m. eastern time
we will be going live what we do is we
do like a short stand-up show before I
don't air that I know you go I want you
air the stand up no like I can tear
people stand up on a podcast it's not
fair to comedians to do that so we don't
air the stand up but it gets the crowd
kind of used to who the guest is a
little bit because the guests become the
comedians that are on the fixing Joe
episode I come up I do a little
monologue about what my issue is I try
to make it as funny as possible and then
I bring the first guest up he tries to
give me advice on it I asked them to
bring a problem I give them advice on
their problem we go to the audience the
audience that's in sitting there in the
club gives us advice and we try to open
the lines for you guys to contact us and
give us advice give me advice give the
guests advice whatever you want to do
but if you want to come out to that show
tomorrow night the stress factory the
stand-up show starts at seven-thirty if
you want to come to that go to stress
factory comedy club com
I think it's you know what it's stress
factory calm or to make it easier for
you just go to joe Matarese calm and
then you can you can click on it there's
a banner the top of my website you could
sit in the audience be there at the live
taping it's really exciting it's really
fun and then we do the the podcast
taping right afterwards and you can be
there for that too gray Club stress
factory okay and I have to thank
somebody huge here at the top this guy
Larry may wonder if he's listening Larry
may made the biggest donation anyone has
ever made on the fixing Joe podcast from
when it started he just crushed
everybody he sends me this big donation
I'm not going to say numbers I think
it's the day before I went to Arizona
with my family so I sent him an email
back saying dude thank you so much for
that really generous donation it
couldn't a common more perfect time I'm
leaving tomorrow to go to Scottsdale
Arizona with my wife and kids we do this
every year we try to go to a warm place
on their winter break and I usually have
to work while I'm there and we make a
little vacation out of it I said this is
great that you sent me this money the
next day he doubles what he sent me and
sends me another donation doubling what
the original donation was which was a
huge donation his first donation was
bigger than anybody has ever sent me and
then he doubles it so I set him all the
free merch did he gets and he's just a
great guy he sent me this long email and
through his email I realized why he is a
fixing Joe fan I can usually tell people
that like my show and why it's almost
like they don't even have to say it in
an email I realize there's either some
sort of depression in the family or
there's something a DD related in the
person or or maybe their child or they
been on SSRIs and they stop taking I'm
or they feel the same way I do they have
a
wife and kids and they're trying to make
their life work correctly and they're
trying meds and all these different
things so Larry you're the best man
thank you so much again oh my god if
everybody donated that listen to my
podcast what Larry donated I would be a
very successful man if everybody just
did that every month I'd be I'd be doing
well I'd be happy cuz let's face it
doesn't everybody's us happiness revolve
around money we try to make it not but
it does and it sucks that it does it
sucks that it has that power over so we
wish it did in right but but it does now
if anybody wants to call into this live
podcast you know I tweeted and
facebooked out the google hangouts
number which sucks it just it seems to
never work right I'll give it to you
it's just the sound isn't as good it's
904 2460 238 but if you want it to
really sound good i recommend skyping
into Matarese 67 m 80 isn't tom ar e se
i have a great guest on the podcast
today i hope he gets my email in time
because uh he yeah okay he got it I just
saw the email Chris Mancini who's a
comedian that I started with oh my god
he must be the same age as me maybe a
year younger maybe a year older I
started in nineteen eighty nine in the
Philadelphia area and Chris did also he
moved to LA early on remember staying I
remember staying in LA and him letting
me stay in his house Jesus a hundred
years ago because my first time ever
going to LA he let me crash at his house
and he was married and he might have had
he might have had his I don't know how
many kids he has because we haven't
talked it's gonna be the first time
we've talked in G's at least 15 years he
looks the same I looked them up on the
Internet I'm like the guy looks the same
he was always a really smart guy and now
he he does this podcast and and I
tweeted it out and I I don't want to get
the the name wrong you know me with my
a.d.d look Chris J Mancini I think it's
called the film nerds Kris J Mancini he
does this podcast and I wanted to do his
and I he doesn't do skyping or phone
calls or anything like that so you I'd
have to be in LA when I do it I keep
trying to set up an LA trip I would love
to do it you know his podcast and
everybody i know that's podcasting
they're all look at his website doesn't
like it doesn't shrink down to fit a
phone hey Chris you might want to get
your website to shrink down and fit a
phone i have it on my phone and it's
just the middle of the website i wonder
if he knows that I can't get the name of
his podcast what the [ __ ] is it be
hilarious crew yeah well his website is
chris j mancini online dot cam and i'm
pretty sure it's called the film nerds I
i guess i would be considered a film
nerd if you only did like five movies
Chris will probably tell me when I
interview him he's gonna be facetiming
me in a couple of minutes if I qualify
to being a film nerd I don't know if it
was the movie Rocky uh Fast Times at
Ridgemont High Rudy a field of dreams
let's see what else uh what are my other
film nerd films um God good fellas let's
think what else goes up there at the
pool I'd have to pull out my DVDs but
definitely a high-fidelity I just love
high fidelity so yeah that MIT then
maybe I would be a film nerd if it was
those movies but I have a feeling
Chris uh probably goes deep this guy's
like he's a he's a screenwriter he's a
television writer he's written books
he's Eddie's been in he's been in LA
it's successfully doing it which is
impressive la spit me out in about a
year and like four months but i think i
left more because i didn't want to be
single forever and the girls out there
sucked so bad that i just i said i got
to get out of here I'm gonna die I'm
gonna be single till I'm 100 for if I
live in Los Angeles so I moved and then
as soon as I came back I met my wife
like two months later boom year later
basically engaged so Chris did the smart
thing I bet i'm guessing i think he
brought his girlfriend maybe and then
they got married out there but he
brought that East Coast girl to Los
Angeles I always tell people if you can
do that you can last in LA a lot longer
than a normal comedian Katt who's single
if you wanna try to have a wife and kids
and try to mix family with career if you
want to do that you you got to bring you
got to bring a girl from New Jersey New
York Philadelphia Washington DC you know
Boston let's face it I don't want to
alienate some of you people comedy
fellow I Ron I just missed it came
across my screen for a second Ron
poliquin as I call him super fan well
your superfan number to Ron because
Larry may just made a humongous donation
but I have a feeling he makes more than
all of us combined I have a feeling he's
very successful because he just that was
a crazy donation and like i said if
everybody did that I'd be killing it Ron
did you say comedy film nerds did I get
it correct so if you want to skype in
during the show skype Matarese 67 okay
podcast is comedy film nerds okay I
don't know what I said that I say nerd
comedy films
that I dyslexic I don't know what I did
all right everybody um what else what
else did I want to talk about this
podcast I guess we should talk about
Arizona auditioning for Sebastian do you
guys know about that if you follow me on
Twitter you know that I that I
auditioned for the Sebastian Maniscalco
pilot I had to put myself on tape while
I was on vacation i wish i was able to
tweet out the video of my audition the
owner of the club hooked me up up this
is him this is my guest so let's take
the guest on and I'll explain more after
I answer faced mo do you hate yeah well
how's it goin oh hey audio only yes I
did say audio only didn't I so i wasn't
sure i asked a question i figure it's a
podcast azhar its audio it is for some
way for some reason I don't know if you
feel well you do all in-person
interviews on your podcast I'm sure
they're never not there from what you
told me in the email right exactly what
happens is if I can see them somehow it
feels a little less weird as a phone
call but I feel I feel awkward when I
see anyone so I like the audio I can you
know what there's a yeah well I was
going to say with our past cuz we're
guys that knew each other a hundred
years ago yeah it then it's we it's I've
had a few of those kind of interviews
really like I haven't seen this guy in
20 years and now I'm looking at him huge
on my computer screen and we both look
old and you're like God
uh oh I wish that weren't true yes we
were you weren't were you able to listen
on wild fire radio.com and what I was
talking about cuz I said some things
about our past I don't know if you heard
any of it um let's just say I may not
know okay good you could refresh my
memory well it wasn't much all I said
was is I think the last time I saw you
was when you let me stay at your place
in LA and I yes and I think you might
have had I don't know how many kids you
have now but you might have had one kid
then no I didn't get that was uh no kids
then yeah it was just me and my I don't
even know if we were married then it
might have been my fiance him I or we
were mad I don't even remember but yeah
we didn't have kids until we moved into
a house okay you had like a it it wasn't
an apartment but it was in a house was
more like a condo I remember had an
upstairs and you know yeah it was a
townhouse has one of those yeah yeah and
it was but it was like we didn't know it
was you know it was an apartment but it
it was nice it was a week II we were
right by the Tar Pits on calendars
perfect location for Los Angeles weird
that you said Tar Pits cuz I didn't say
that at the top of the podcast but that
is a vivid memory of you explaining to
me that we were near Tar Pits and I
remember like I grew up in South Jersey
I'm like what where ya what Tar Pits I'm
like what is that well yeah I mean with
you we grew up in like we did in philly
in jersey you realize that always you
talking about the roads what is he you
know we talking about is it that hot
here yeah yeah what nowhere what say to
cuz now i'm familiar with LA over the
years but how long ago was that was that
more than 15 years ago can you remember
how long you been gotta be it's gotta be
at least 15 years because we've been
married for about 15 but we we lived in
that place for a couple years before we
were married so it's got to be between
15 and 20 that how scary is that it's
weird that it doesn't seem like that
long ago
like do you remember when you stayed the
thing that happened to you oh oh my god
this i'm still laughing about this you
came you it you would never really
stayed no way before no and I knew you
were from you know New York New Jersey
and I said now look you got to be
careful crossing the street they will
ticket you for jaywalking here and you
were like no way no way I'm like I'm
telling you just be careful and then you
went out you did your meetings you and
your day and you came back that night
and you looked at me when I got a ticket
for jaywalking I do remember getting a
ticket for jaywalking but I thought it
was when I lived in LA cuz I live no you
got it when you stayed with me the same
day I warned you not to get one yes in
burbank right was it burbank i remember
getting one in burbank yeah oh my god i
still remember that I tried the law I
tried to lie I tried to pull like a
Jersey Italian guy I was like I don't
have my wallet I thought that was gonna
work which didn't yeah it didn't did it
no it didn't he's like you don't have a
wallet on you and I totally did and it
was like terrible and you know i don't
think i ever paid that ticket it cuts it
just it disappeared after like it took a
while and it went up to like five six
seven hundred dollars right and then
there's a statute of limitations on
jaywalking violations I thought for sure
they would have done something like
ticketed my car later or if I tried to
boot it booted your leg its body it's
something you tell every East Coast
person when they come to class you don't
don't don't think you're gonna run
across the street cuz you'll get a
hundred dollar ticket oh my god yeah I
remember that and I also said at the
beginning of the podcast you did la the
smartest way possible which is you
brought a girlfriend from the east coast
there right actually no the first year
because we did a long-distance
relationship which was very hard but we
made it work
cuz i went i needed to decide if i liked
it and i wanted to stay there and then
she visited a bunch of times and then we
decide all right we'll give it a shot I
mean it was it was really kind of one of
those like all right let's see what
happened so she moved out and then she
got it you know she got a job right away
when when when she came out to LA people
she's not in the business she's a
scientist so you know it's a good mix I
mean she works to save lives and I tell
jokes to drunks so karmically you know
it works out well we have a set up we
have a similar similar situation I mean
I'm my wife is a neuropsychologist so oh
so she gets paid every single week too
yeah yeah my wife is does research on
Alzheimer's disease so I mean it's kind
of like a scientist right absolutely no
that's exactly like a scientist yeah now
but so I was almost right which I said
what you did correctly is you were in a
relationship already because if you yes
you never had to be single in LA cuz
it's really sad and horror it's not easy
and I saw a lot of my friends kind of go
through it and have things
self-destructed you know I still see it
some of my friends are still single and
it's and it gets harder especially what
it gets harder when you anywhere when
you're single and older but it gets even
harder in Los Angeles because everyone
has that little bit of crazy that you're
not sure is gonna turn into a big bit of
crazy and it only shows up four months
later into a relationship I could I
don't think i ever got past like three
weeks with a girl when I was in I was
only there for about a year and four
months but well you were on an
accelerated timeline then for the crazy
yeah well it was always fascinating to
me because I was always the crazy one in
my relationships but all of a sudden it
flipped when I moved to LA I was like
I'm the normal one this is we yeah I'm
in bizarro land is this oh my god I
dated like the I guess the typical
things like the managers assistant a lot
of guys I know and updating their
managers assistant or
just not on that that always works out I
never did I never went down the comedian
road though when I lived in LA I never
dated comics thank god i don't really
like i never liked girl comedians it's
it seems too manly to me i don't like a
manly girl like girl comedians you ever
notice they're very guy like you could
say anything in front of them and i
don't know oh yeah it's like hanging out
with a buddy and oftentimes they will
out dirty you yeah yeah yeah like my
wife is easily offend some times yeah
sometimes you can hang out with real
comedians and then like I start blushing
my god yeah just I'm feeling
uncomfortable here now I'm guessing your
cult you probably have to be the same
age as me did you start stand up in
Philly in like 89 or 90 somewhere in
there let's see take graduated and yeah
about there about 89 88 89 yeah cuz i
started right when I started college and
the first comedian I ever met was Todd
glass who who actually was performing at
my college while I was there like I was
like a freshman what do you sell
approached him said I liked what you did
or you tell him you wanted to be a
comedian I didn't I just said hi thought
you were great and then thought I would
never see him again was before I decided
I wanted to do it are you friends with
him though absolutely we just saw Todd I
see him periodically in fact he's in we
shot a documentary on podcasting and
Todd is is in it so we got to profile
him it's really cool it's called earbuds
the podcasting documentary I saw it on
your website I sold it yeah yeah we're
just finishing it up and it'll get
released this year but man it's what uh
what if the documentaries take forever
earth oh good no I know guys that have
done them and then I've I've done pieces
I've been in pieces of other people's it
seems like todd todd glass might win the
award for being in the most comedy
documentaries yeah I think yeah and this
will only add to his uh his collection
for sure yeas he's so great on camera
too and he gets these very serious he
gets uh he goes into what it was like to
come out on a podcast and you know to
seek us Todd is like he's like a manic
you know comic who just goes all over
the place all the time but to see him in
this documentary focused and serious and
talking about things that he really feel
strongly about and believes in it's
really a cool departure because you see
him funny but then you also see no
there's a real serious guy behind this
too yeah he gets here I've had him on my
show a few times and he said something
really interesting to me and I wonder if
he said it in your movie because i think
it was when i first started podcasting
and I you know the fixing Joe format I
opened myself up and I asked for advice
and I told it right you know everybody's
podcasting and everybody makes fun of
you for podcasting cuz everybody's doing
it and tacos well everybody's doing
stand up to and we do stand-up and like
it was like a perfect thing to say oh
yeah you're right we there's a million
of us doing stand-up but we do it like
he's like if you like podcasting and you
have an interesting angle do it you know
there's no there's no quota that needs
to be filled on podcasting it's like all
right we're done we don't need any more
haha it's like true it's like bands you
know it's any art art form its bands you
know it's like what are you gonna tell
like um you know like death cab for
cutie sorry we already have enough bands
you can't be a band anymore it's
meaningless the one flip side to that
though is it's like doing a podcast just
to do a podcast that I disagree with if
you want to do a podcast to a podcast
but don't do it just because everyone
else is doing it do it because you have
something to say and you you want to
actually express yourself sure well one
of the reasons i started my podcast and
what's so great about it
and you realize that all of show
business has become this now which is I
had an idea that I wanted to do and it
was always wrapped around like a TV show
you know I was like oh I want to do a
sitcom or I'm a radio guy who seeks
advice from the callers like and I
always wanted to do a sitcom about that
and then like I heard one podcast and I
was like I can just wait I can just do
it I could just do yeah I don't need to
do a show about it I can do it I don't
need the show let's no one needs
permission to be on the internet yeah
it's great uh um what did you learn in
the documentary about podcasting is
there anything you learned that you
didn't you didn't know or that you've
discovered what we did is we kind of had
some hints of what we were going to
expect but what happened was as we were
shooting a lot more threads kind of
emerged like what we wanted we wouldn't
we didn't want to do like a history of
podcasting just interview like Marc
Maron yeah by castings great blah blah
blah so what we did instead was we
focused on the personal connection
between the podcaster and the fan so a
lot of the documentary is actually the
fans and how they interact and react to
the podcasters okay so we actually shot
all over the world we went to Australia
and Japan to interview fans so we
actually we opened it up really
worldwide and one of the things that we
did notice was there was a lot of a lot
of people that are kind of closed off
and have certain mental illnesses or
mental issues podcasting it was their
window to the world and actually helped
give them comfort and make them feel
better like they weren't as alone and
that was something that was also
humbling because you know we're making
jokes into a microphone into our
computers you know we don't we don't
make that connection that you know maybe
were really helping someone through a
tough time or whatever and that was a
couple things first of all it makes what
we do worthwhile even when we're not
making any money and it also was very
humbling that were actually you know in
a weird way kind of helping in a small
way so that was one thing that really
resonated especially with us just as we
were shooting and I've
actually said that about stand up I
don't think I said it in a documentary
but I've said it to like interview you
and some was interviewing me I've said
right those but the best moments they go
what's the best moment and I would say
it's that moment when someone comes up
to you and says like my dad died
yesterday or two days ago I you made me
forget about it for 90 minutes and you
made me crack up and thank you so much
like those are the moments and yeah you
realize that maybe it so you're saying
that would you say the bigger population
of people that are a little socially off
are the ones listening to podcast the
most or no no I don't think so i think
it's a it's a cross section thing about
podcasting is you know people ask what's
the demographic of podcasting and it's
you can't even answer that because it's
everyone it's you know we've interviewed
everyone from you know retired
schoolteachers to college kids it's an
emerging medium that everyone's kind of
gravitating towards what they what they
like and what they want the one thing
that's definitely was a common thread is
that it's it means something personal to
people even if you're not having issues
with mental illness or whatever if
you're just enjoying a show you're
connecting with that more than the way
you're connecting with a TV or a TV show
or a movie because the it's very very
personal even more personal than radio
you feel like you're being talked
directly to and one of the reasons to is
we're not we're unfiltered where it's
basically easy eavesdropping on a
conversation I mean we barely edit our
shows unless someone says something
crazy I doubt you do much editing on
your show no yeah only when someone asks
you to or you realized I might have burn
a bridge and said something do i yeah
yeah we have a system now for Graham and
I for comedy film nerds we look at each
other and write down the time code
that's a good idea ipad headed after the
guest leaves so you just look at each
other and right yeah yeah oh god I wish
I was that I in tune to know to do that
I do usually remember what I said and I
probably should write it down well this
is new to me
going live thing I've only been doing
this for like a month how do you like it
it's it's odd I'm him like that
literally the first the listeners
couldn't tell i tried to hide it but
literally like the first three minutes
of my podcast GarageBand was saying you
have no audio in pudding so it was
recording nothing but I could tell by
this app that's on my phone that allows
it to stream live on wildfire radio is
was streaming because it shows me a time
count on it so I knew I was being heard
but I wasn't recording so i had to like
i had to be and then talk at the same
time it's like I had to talk like a
radio guy talks and and keep my story
going as I'm trying to click around the
preferences and get things get it to
record don't you have a staff of
producers helping you it's my I've had
I've had interns in in the past i i i
had an intern who was like I called him
my producer but I used to say to him
like you live in Bucks County like well
I the stuff i would really need a
producer for like I need you right next
to me when we're recording you know and
uh I don't know or you know I don't know
how do you go about booking your guests
do you have a do you have a team at all
we have we started with interns and now
we're at the point now we're kind of
higher like some part-time help here and
there but what we really need is a
full-time person because we do so much
we don't we just have the we don't just
have the podcast we have we have a giant
online store we have the website and we
have movie reviews being written by
people and then we have a book and the
feature and all that stuff so it's kind
of like a company where a podcast is is
part of it but is the anchor to
everything that we do so it we have
someone to come in and kind of help out
with everything but we find that you
don't want to overload anybody whether
it's an intern or part-time person you
can have like one person produces the
show for you and then you have one
person doing social media this way if
you're using interns you don't overload
anyone everybody can kind of give like
you know five you know
five to ten hours a week but we found
that sometimes when we wanted to try to
have an intern do everything they would
only stick around for a week or two yeah
I had a lot of those bail or go back
yeah they go back to school at the end
of the summer or they go back to school
and the middle of July you go wait a
minute it's you're not in school I gotta
go bye this sucks I'm working for free
Celia uh what would I have gotten out
now I don't need free improv tickets
thank you yeah that's always the sale to
at the top like oh you can hang with me
yeah you can come to my spots in this in
New York City and just I know why oh now
that I have you on I'm realizing that
this is probably what this episode is
gonna be about I have so many questions
I here's another question is is how to
build the fan base and um why I'm asking
you that and something I didn't talk
about yet on the podcast is uh I talked
to two publicists today and I've been
thinking about hiring a publicist and
and they're expensive I mean you know
from being in LA I mean I yes I found
some reasonable ones that aren't thus
right high-end kind which usually means
they don't have as many contexts they're
not going to be as good as the five
thousand dollar a month uh right
publicist but I'm wondering because I'm
what I'm trying to do right now and I
don't know if you know if this came up
in the I'm sure came up in the
documentary is these guys how do I build
my fan base and how do i what makes me
stand out and how does it start to you
know blossom well what I could also do
is refer you to the LA pod fest podcast
feed we actually record all of the
panels and stuff like that with audience
growth and with people that that are
kind of more into it than I hate them
because they're people that run the
networks and the advertising and all
that stuff but I could tell you one
thing about publicist it's a great job
because all you have to do is take
someone's money and not guarantee any
results oh yeah it's the best job ever
and sometimes way nothing
yeah yeah it's like you can't even do
that with a baker well give you a dollar
for a donut and I may or may not make
you that donut so so if publicist is
really a crapshoot if you get a good one
and they get it in front of the right
journalist and you have a giant piece
written in the New York Times then great
but you know it's like you're rollin
dice sometimes you're better off working
through social media and possibly buying
ads on Twitter or these places and then
to actually build your followers on
Twitter and then that translates into a
podcast listeners the other thing you do
a lot is you go on other podcasts you
have different guests on yours it's that
that's the basic cross-pollination go on
as many different ones as you can and
have as many different guests as you can
on yours once again that's what sucks
about being in New York there yeah for
some reason a lot of us aren't doing it
here and untrue it says it's a south
it's a Southern California la kind of
thing right now still um I'm uh I'm on
all things comedy which is bill burr and
I'll magicals yeah that's what that's
what world you're on at how many
Filner's design yeah so everybody that's
on that channel you were the only one
out of almost all of them but know what
you know what I'm wrong you you came on
my show they all come on my show but
right every one of them says I can't
have you on unless you're here in LA
like that's what they all say and you
know it's it's got to the point i
remember it was a joke like three years
ago someone made a joke said hey I went
to LA for a podcast season like that was
the joke that's pretty funny but now its
true like you got a book a week to go do
a bunch of podcasts well what I would
recommend and this is what you guys know
Keith him the girl was in New York
they're also in the documentary but what
they did is when we program them at LA
pod fest they came in a couple weeks out
they did literally a tour they did all
the podcasts did the festival did a
couple comedy shows and they went back
to New York they maximized all the time
that they had here so the it's
definitely it as crazy as it sounds
people are doing that
that right now well it were especially
for a comedian like I just did a on
Valentine's Day weekend it was but
Valentine's Day came on a sunday this
year I did a theater in town I grew up
in for the first time ever in my forever
comedy career I was like let me try to
do a theater you know and just promote
the [ __ ] out of it myself I'm gonna do
every darn podcast there is and I'm
going to do a little bit of radio in the
Philly market and then try to get a
newspaper article written which I did
and it worked but like and I sold it out
you know so now I'm going to try to do
more great more of these little theaters
down in that area down there because you
can kind of go 30 miles each way and the
radio stations down there still hit it
but like the only is the best thing
about that Joe creatively you're
performing to a sold-out crowd that's
there to see you it was a mere not going
to quote comedy club and wondering who
they're going to see ya that's the
that's the most creative rewarding thing
is when people come out they know what
to expect their rd you've already won
them over before you get there yeah it's
like called my agents and I said listen
this is all I want to do I don't even
think I want to go because they can't
even get me in these clubs half of these
clubs say no they don't care it's weird
like and you've been on America's Got
Talent yeah but they just that but five
years ago they would just kind of you
know you had a reputation and they'd
bring you in and things have changed in
the last I'd say even three years it's
just every year it gets harder and
harder unless you know even like 50,000
Twitter followers is like a joke to them
they don't care like you got to have
hundreds of thousands and be able to
really sit once again that gets harder
at a comedy club because let's not
because you I sold out 350 seats on a
Saturday but if I go to a comedy club
that seats 300 people I gotta do five or
six shows I mean that's a lot more
people I'd rather just consolidate it in
the one-to-one show yeah and here's the
other thing too you're not making all
that money for someone else yeah it was
I made triple what I make at a comedy
club and I was
of course and and then I tried this was
well I never really did the live podcast
in front of the audience but I did it at
stand-up Scottsdale last week on the
Sunday night and all of a sudden I was
like I usually hate listening to
podcasts where there's an audience there
cuz I you know people like this intimacy
the long-form interview all that bright
but you know what I am I was like I
think I kind of like this better maybe
it's because I don't do it a lot we love
our live shows we we absolutely love
doing a comedy film nerds live and what
you'll do you'll find is that you'll
have a different vibe for your live show
it took us a little while to figure it
out but what we do is we make it a more
of a presentation like we do movie
trailers and games and really make it
like a cool fun live show and guests and
you know you a lot of podcasts they just
find their thing so I'm going to do
exactly what they do on the show and
that's fine other ones do a completely
different show live than they do with
the studio and it's there's no rules you
could do whatever you want that's what's
great about yes what I did that made it
work better i thought then sometimes
doing it this way is that the guests got
to do like seven minutes stand-up sets
we did like a 45-minute stand-up show
and then we did an hour along podcast
taping after the stand-up show will put
right but what made it great was is
they're talking about their issues and
what they need help with but now they
saw them do stand up so they kind of
know who they are a little bit so it
made it funnier and more fun when they
were revealing [ __ ] about themselves you
know right absolutely yeah because I
remember I had pitched a show years ago
where we shot this little mini pilot at
carolines and it was called what's so
funny that was the name of the show and
it was basically like it was Jim Norton
and RD Laing they did stand up but with
a doctor a psychologist on stage taking
notes and then yeah and then him and I
were the hosts like it was kind of like
love lines like the comedian and the
doctor and we interviewed the comedian
with his notes and like psychoanalyzed
them and it was funny because the crowds
there comedians just
naturally go for the funny we know how
to do it you know so and then the
audience gets to ask questions too but
that and then every comedian after that
show went home and cried into their
pillow it was fun Artie lat Artie Lange
actual Howard Stern liked it so much cuz
he got here I think he got to see it
somehow Artie's portion and he aired
Artie's portion on when are back in the
day Howard Stern used to do the what did
they call it uh but they had like a
channel where you could watch the Howard
Stern Show not when it was on e when it
was on satellite radio I guess it was
cool why am I stuck with this wasn't
Howard 101 it was called like I don't
know what they could they had a channel
I don't remember what the [ __ ] I never I
never I believe you buddy but they aired
so uh so yeah okay so yeah the publicist
is it doesn't sound like it's a it's a
definite thing here yeah the publicist
is what it's a gamble it's you know it
could work out great or it could be a
waste of money it's one of those
unknowns it's a it's a diet it's a dice
throw you know if you get a really good
referral somebody goes this guy's great
they'll take carrier you know that might
be good but you just never know how many
episodes a week do you guys do on yours
we do between one and two we do a
regular episode that sometimes we do a
spoiler or special episode we will go
through a movie from top to bottom and
analyze it including the ending so we
tell people this is a spoiler up for
like you know Hail Caesar or whatever
and then we go into it like it's
basically an episode you listen to after
you've seen the film or if you have no
intention of seeing the film that's the
other reason people listen to it so so
we do about one to two a week so
probably about average about six months
okay do you [ __ ] do you ask for
donations and all that kind of stuff we
do all sorts of different things like we
we have a full online store that we but
we don't just sell comedy film its
products we sell products from like a
lot of different podcast
and comedian silly cariola Dana Gould
merchandise thrilling adventure hour so
we kind of open that up to the other
comedians as a service and we make some
money from that and also we do ad reads
that's the other way we make money and
occasionally people donate but mainly we
we like to people have people just buy
something in the stores they're kind of
getting a little bit of something for
their money you know just hand in a
sketch although we could ask for a fair
amount of money for the movie so we're
not going to be asking for donations for
a long time and we raised 140 grand on
Kickstarter so and it was a podcast
listeners that gives all my guests
listeners and podcasters to podcaster
stepped up in that and also helps fund
that film can you say what your biggest
donation out of any podcast listener was
what else I double team no I can say a
name is fine Kickstarter caps everything
in 10,000 so that's as high as you could
go Doug Benson put in 10,000 wow he's
kicking ass at podcasting huh jeez it's
a mean oh yeah podcasting live shows and
he's really a guy that's kind of figured
out every little niche of the of the
internet for here and and and who gets
your ads for you do you because all
things calmly doesn't seem to be
bringing they'll I don't know what their
deal is over there like yeah yeah we got
some ads and then you don't hear
anything well we we get our ads for we
get our ads from a couple different
places we have it one dedicated ad rep
that happened to be a childhood friend
of gram so that that kind of helped us
out in in a unique way but the other
places all things comedy does get us
some ads sorry I they do or will your at
the baby I don't know it's I think this
business is all about face times like
I'm talking to these people on the phone
they're all in California right you know
you're probably do you do you record in
their studio ever no no we just do it in
there in that and the garage but the
other place we get ads from is the
hosting company we were with lipson so
am on and occasionally an ad comes
through from them but they're they're
the lowest paying ones but they still
show up every once in a while right so
the one thing I found about advertising
is that there's no one place you get all
your ad
like one month you'll get a lot from one
place and you get nothing from somewhere
else and then it'll reverse or whatever
but the best thing I could do I could
tell you for that is have somebody start
to research these companies and approach
them directly to try to get like an ad
deal for a couple months here and there
that's you know that's what I had told
my producer I said listen because I'm
about to sign with a company that's
gonna get me ads but they take their you
know they take thirty percent so I said
to him before they start go make cold
calls i go how hard could i go you know
the company's you're a podcast fan it's
all its audible.com its flowers calm its
stance calm we know the company's call
them yes where space deals directly with
podcasters here there's a lot of clea
there's a lot of companies that will
deal directly some of them will only go
through ad agencies like audible but
there's a mix and there's here's the
thing there's new companies coming
online all the time that want to get
into the space so you know there's
plenty of places he mean we we've had
advertisers from a you know just to
create apps you know and they've ever
done a couple episodes yeah so there's
yeah so whether the app works or not it
doesn't matter what sometimes you wonder
if you should yeah promote your own
podcast on another podcast like I
started hearing that people are placed
in marin on Maron's podcast you'll hear
a commercial for who was it that I just
heard it just started a podcast and he
promoted it on Marin I was like yep
we've had that to where you know people
like a new podcast will say and we do a
sliding scale kind of thing if you're an
indie guy an artist like a comic book
artist dhirubhai you know or a podcaster
we don't charge the same rate is like
you know a square space okay well I'm
learn I'm learning as much from talking
to you as these guys that are running
major ad companies I feel like they
don't even know because it's so new they
just guess and say [ __ ] I'm like you
don't know yeah yeah anyone you know
that old quote about the movie business
anybody who tells you that they know
everything is full [ __ ] hahaha true so
so we'll talk a lil
a bit about issues i'm curious because i
haven't seen you in a long time is there
yeah is that if i had to say to you is
there anything you would like to discuss
where you think you could use some
advice any anything it could be it could
be something minimal or it could be
something deep and anybody struggle with
yeah you know what most of my struggles
have been career-wise like especially
for I've been kind of without an agent
and a manager for a while I'm trying to
get back into writing I mean I'm a
published author i've written for TV
shows and movies and stuff but I'm kind
of in a slump right now so it's one of
the things I'd like to actually get back
more into is uh is into writing so with
you if you have a bearish if you're a
showrunner and if you can hire me yeah
it's it's funny cuz i just said i just
sent an email i just sent an email out
to one of my favorite he might be my
favorite showrunner of all time and and
a friend of mine had him well coupe
steve cooper who you know yeah of course
steve cooper had him on his radio show
and said how great of a guy he was and
that he'd do your podcast and he gave me
his email and told him about me and i
sent him an email today and i'm praying
he gets back to me is a Phil Rosenthal I
love I just oh yeah yeah from everyone
loves Raymond yeah I don't know if you
ever read it he has this book called how
to turn your life into a sitcom and it's
it's so good and I tell every comedian
you should you should basically read
this book I mean it really write it I
mean the one major note is the manna
every comedian knows this but sometimes
it takes us 25 years to realize it the
more you have the more specific we are
the funnier it is you can be so specific
about your own life and it translated as
funny to everybody and it a yea years to
find that out I think that's a hundred
percent true one of the things that got
me actually back on track a couple years
ago is when I had my first child I was
really freaked out about it and I wasn't
sure what was going on I was so scared
to be a dad I was reading these
parenting books and then none of them
were helping me so I
wrote one I wrote one to help a guy who
was scared about being the dad to become
a dad was it's called pacify me handbook
for the freaked-out new dad and I made
it very specific and very person I was
like you know I've never really written
like this before and I got an agent and
it went to Simon & Schuster and got
bought on the first submission really so
yeah and it was like oh maybe I you know
I should be getting a little more
personal and then I started developing
as a show we went and pitched it out it
didn't it didn't it got pretty close to
it like CBS but then it didn't sell so
but then you know what happens with a
lot of agents and managers and you know
they send stuff out to one place it
doesn't sell and then everyone loses
interest so it's a heat-seeking market
you're you're hot for like a few seconds
and then oh yeah we're on to the next
thing oh yeah was that something that
you want to do is write for a sitcom or
what do you did you like writing books
better you know what it's I just love
the art of writing so much that I've
enjoyed writing on shows I've enjoyed
writing on movies and I really enjoyed
writing the book too in fact I've been
trying to get kind of like a sequel to
the book publisher I haven't been able
to yet I'm still working on it's about
you know when your children get older
and you have like how old are your kids
I have an eight-year-old son and a
four-year-old daughter oh and your own
for your own okay yeah I have a I've 11
and a seven so they're slightly ahead
but that's not by much not much and yeah
and you've been married longer than me
so you waited awhile to have kids oh I
did yeah I put it off for as long as I
can yeah so yeah the title nor the
second book is I'm gonna either eat it
or break it because that's that's what
toddlers do so but yeah but yeah I've
been just working on that and just one
of the things that happen is I kind of
got into podcasting which I've really
enjoyed but it also it takes time to
build up a company and run it and it's
kind of taken time away from writing
which I you know I'm trying to get kind
of course correct and get back into now
yeah
yeah writing is one of those things I
remember I i had a development deal
years and years ago probably after i
hung at your apartment with NBC and I
that's what moved me to LA because I
thought I was one of those guys that
thought I had to be there because i want
to write the pilot with the showrunner i
don't want to be emailing him it's like
it was the stupidest i think it was at
one of my biggest mistakes cuz I could I
could I could have had all that money on
the East Coast and continued to perform
and make money but I moved to LA and
then just ate through it very fast right
and then as soon as the development of
the show never got filmed you know they
really that's weird yeah and I think I
I'm a deja vu I think we might have I
think we may have hung out once after I
hung at your apartment like a fee maybe
another time when I went to LA it's
entirely possible i think we preserve I
don't know what I'm right the improv or
something something with like Paul
Tompkins or something I don't know why
I'm thinking of that cuz i remember you
doing you know what I saw you to stand
up somewhere and um I remember a joke
about you saying it's about 30 minutes
that was like your joke they must things
you were sick of saying in LA right I
don't know why I remember I don't
remember where that was it's about 30 i
remember that bid to yet okay you always
saying it's about 30 minutes away hey
sorry i missed your show that's the
other thing and then you had that home
really glad for you that was yeah yeah
but I oh god yeah so i thought i had to
write it but I remember how fun that was
trying to write a pilot and all that
kind of [ __ ] so i can imagine if you're
in l a-- that's what was hard about la
too is if you want to be a TV writer it
can be heartbreaking because you're so
close to all the studios you're watching
people left and right do what you want
to do oh yeah yeah it's definitely it's
exciting and incredibly disheartening
sometimes at the same time depending on
how your day is going I remember walking
on to the the Sony lot to be interviewed
as a dress
der for one of Adam Sandler films and
this was like you know it was just a
cool feeling it was the first time I'd
gotten discovered from a film festival
one of my short film and I'm walking
into a giant studio lot being
interviewed to direct a film and it
would like one of those moments that
like you know this is the first time
this has ever happened you always
remember kind of that like first like oh
my god this is kind of what I've always
wanted and now I'm here I'm on the locks
so I never directed it Adam Sandler but
just that moment of walking on the lot
being interviewed as a director was
amazing oh god I can imagine oh yeah I
just remember being on those sitcom
stages her son that's something that
still lives inside me as the one thing
that I just want to do more than
anything like I even yeah i even texted
steve cooper i said um he's my pal Phil
Rosenthal I said he's my he's what did I
say he's my dream showrunner to have for
the dream show I want to do like he's
the guy i don't know why because i
somehow I could always compared myself
to Ray Romano I don't know why I've
always found a lot of similarities I'm a
fan of his I think he's like a subtle
great actor that like people don't even
like probably even look at as a great
actor and I just think he's so good at
it that it doesn't look like he's doing
anything one of those kind rhymes oh
yeah like David Duchovny he's always
gonna play Fox Mulder no matter what
he's doing yeah yeah they're just it's
just like no work at all to do it right
it's like yeah I get it you're in
californication but you're still Fox
Mulder so so so your issue is you wanna
you want to write again really you want
it you want to get out of this writing
slump yes Oh down now I remember what
why I brought up the LA and the show I
did I just remembered it was cuz he the
guy this guy's name was Matt Wickline he
was the showrunner for the pilot
I had and he said that he had it he used
to put a sticker on his computer that
said sit down and write cuz that's the
hardest but that you have to just sit
out and write every day no matter what
you have to do it so and then [ __ ]
starts to happen but you gotta actually
[ __ ] turn your computer on like you
got a good advice I mean I mean that's
probably what every writer tells the
other person but I mean I guess if you
don't have an idea for a story it's hard
to sit down right yeah I mean I've
always had a that's never been a problem
with me I'm very prolific I'm I always
have ideas and stories and I've got like
two other screenplays I'm trying to so
right now I actually sold a screenplay
from a play date that's the great thing
about you know being in a way to go you
need to Prince me on that one yeah oh no
when I tell you the story you will not
be depressed for sure you will feel
sorry for me ah Julia yeah I had a play
date and I said you know as a writer and
I have some I write comedy right our
scripts and it was a casting director he
said oh I work for the small company
after dark but they get distributed with
by Lions Gate I'll send a script over so
they I sent a script over they liked it
they bought it and they were going to
shoot it in and I was like oh great well
can I direct it like well we'll
interview to direct it and we'll see
what happens i said okay so I went in I
brought in storyboards concepts i was
ready to direct this movie i had
everything ready to go i even had a lift
of people that would i would hire and
all the stuff and it was called asylum
and it's about that a SWAT team that
goes in to investigate demonic
possession in an insane asylum so that's
that's the part story okay so they say
no and I said okay so they go to
Bulgaria they shoot this movie with a
Bulgarian director I don't hear anything
for it's like it's not a small movie
it's like 11.4 million so they spend
money on it the trailer comes out I said
okay it's not what I would have done but
at least I have a feature film done so
they call me and they say hey we need to
meet with you I said why because well
let's meet and then they go but we need
to meet you at a bar I said why can't we
meet in the office is it just works
playing at the bar is that ok so
I go I meet them at a bar they start
buying me drinks and they go to me they
said the producer that took your script
to Bulgaria went rogue through your
script away shot 80 minutes of footage
that makes no sense now we have nothing
to deliver two lions gate can you fix it
for us that's what I said I said what he
just started shooting what did he shoot
denied it well apparently not one page
of my script after I saw the footage so
here's the thing then I said I don't
even know there's nothing I can do I
said well it came out so bad can you
make it a comedy I said I'd maybe so
okay but but I what like what does he
mean like wouldn't cut the whole movie
and or get rid of all that and rewrite
it what do I don't that's where I wasn't
sure of so I said this is we started
discussing like well I don't even know
how I would do this and they said we
have a little bit more money you could
shoot some wrap arounds a new footage I
said okay let me think about it so I saw
it and I came back to them and I said
the only way I could make this into a
comedy is if that I shot behind the
scenes wraparound footage of how a low
budget car company destroys a movie as
it's being made and then we can have
editors actually watch the footage and
mystery science theater jokes underneath
it right so basically making fun of them
for what they did right surprisingly
they said yes so why is this a this
isn't a negative story it is okay hold
on oh so I call up a bunch of my buddies
I call up a comedian Mike minute i call
up Dean Haglund from the x-files and we
fly down to they wouldn't let me shoot
in la's because there was some weird
flimflamming thing they wanted to shoot
in Baton Rouge so is it ok so we shot in
baton rouge in they they were hammering
me on the budget so much that in order
for me to get Dean hagwon who is a
professional actor from the x-files
acting for many many years I had to give
up my rental cars but they would pay for
his hotel so we start shooting and I
bang it out
in a two and a half day so I got all my
wrap around it's all together and I
start putting the director's cut
together they're giving me the crew was
great but you know the producers are
like looking at me like uh you know this
is costing too much and you almost done
and all this stuff and then my favorite
part was they go they went behind my
back to the rest of the cast and they
said we really love what Dean is doing
because Dean a gwan is a professional
improviser and he was really lighting up
the scenes and doing great and they
don't they didn't understand what improv
was so they just told the other actors
to just say whatever you want yes that's
because that's what improv is it it
doesn't match the character imagine the
scene it doesn't match the action it
doesn't drive the story forward they're
just saying whatever they want and it
was a fight to actually get actors down
there because they thought well you know
funny is funny we'll just use an improv
troupe in New Orleans because yeah cuz
that's all you need every comedian is
interchangeable right Joe so shot it I
did I did a I got it the best thing I
could I got a director's cut together I
thought it would be kind of a cool
Mystery Science Theater thing would
retitle it death of a horror movie so
people would know and then I turned it
in the one good thing i did on the deal
is because i didn't want to pay me is
that i got the rights back to my
original script which was good so i
don't hear from anything they that was
the deal they were like oh I know
they'll have any more money to pay you
like even watch then then you're giving
me back the rights to my script so I can
actually make it properly next time so
they agreed to that so I can actually
make a proper horror movie next time but
then what they did is they stopped
contact with me the movie came out
without even me knowing about it they
defense the podcast fans told me they
discovered it they found it and they
never rebranded it they still called it
asylum to trick the horror fans into
actually watching it not knowing that it
was a horror comedy so so it's out there
as and they cut out half the jokes
because they said they didn't test well
and um that's when I know I called
[ __ ] because there's no
they would have paid for it to be tested
it was one of those things where the
interns didn't get some of the jokes the
comedians were making so they just
dropped them out so instead of having a
joke that maybe half the people will get
theirs now like dead air and half the
places which is exactly what you want so
I I said that you know I made lemonade
twice they made lemons three times so
this movie it exists it shouldn't exist
you can actually see asylum its on
demand it's a lion's gate actually
released it so there's a movie that
exists that is a hybrid of horror comedy
it has myself Dean Hagelin Mike Schmidt
and Stephen Raya the guy from The Crying
Game in it and a bunch of Bulgarian
pretending to be a SWAT team and you got
paid nothing well I got paid for the
original the original spent money yeah
but I didn't get paid to fix it but I
got the I got the rights back so was
worth it to me because now I can
actually make it properly all right I
got art let's end with this cuz I had
this debate with Artie Lange recently on
this movie and he swore he was right and
I swear I'm right now you know the movie
will write Martin Scorsese the King of
Comedy you know it very well right right
now the ending of the movie when Robert
De Niro is in the bar and he watches the
stand-up set that he did any and the
cops grabbed him and arrest him and put
his you know and take him away and he
says to the cops something I don't
remember exact words what he says the
cops are basically it's like like
looking at them like wasn't I great and
the cops go your I was terrible and like
they they like arrest him right and then
that voiceover starts and they show kind
of his career the end of the movie my
yeah and vaguely I haven't seen it for a
long time well yeah my take on that
movie is Robert De Niro was delusional
as Rupert Pupkin and he thought he had a
good set he didn't he just thought he
did and that voiceover was like a
delusional thought process and that
guy's head he didn't really go on the
Jerry Langford show and
amazing like that was in his [ __ ]
mind I don't know why that's how I take
that ending do you I think he definitely
I think they definitely broadcasted the
set yeah I think he was on there I'm not
saying he didn't perform though yeah
right but I don't think it went well I
just think he thinks it went well no but
i think it was also if we get a little
technical little inside baseball e is
the way that the media and also you know
networks manipulate and show everything
it doesn't matter that he was a shitty
comic and that he was delusional you
know when you're on TV under that
spotlight and you have a live are
answered laugh track they can make you
look good no matter how horrible you
actually are mm-hmm so i think that was
part of kind of the message that
everything is kind of fake what you see
on television so um is that what did you
think the voice-over cuz the voice-over
comes on and makes it look like he had
this like stellar career and everything
and then they show him in some lounge
and then it like freeze frames so you
kind of have this weird ending feeling
like you're not thinking i think yeah I
think that was in his head too for sure
I think it was a delusion but it also
was up for interpretation like is bad
publicity you know the only there is no
bad publicity is that's something when
he got out of prison you know because
you know today like with reality stars
and shows it's you know it doesn't you
don't need any talent you people a
plastered all over TV and uh um you know
magazines and headlines so I think that
end of that movie i think it was sick
illusion but in his head he was doing
all these things and and he might've
even be sitting in reality in a prison
cell i think it was deliberately vague
like you had to kind of interpret how
that movie actually and yeah it was so I
think those are some possibilities but i
agree with you i think in it you know my
interpretation was that it was delusion
yeah that's what uh yeah that that's the
way I feel too that it yeah it's one of
those movies they wanted you to leave
going whoa i'm not sure like they wanted
right person what it exactly yeah yeah
there's there's people are going to have
a different view and then added sparks
debate for sure i'm trying to think of
another move
in the last five years that was like
people were unsure on the ending there
was something i saw and i can't remember
what that it's something big there was
like a big blockbuster to had a you
could take it either way ending and i
can't remember what the [ __ ] it was
sorry sorry i'm not i also own the film
that you're talking about but i have no
idea what you're talking probably own
it's something that might have either
was up for an Oscar or won the Oscar it
had this guy who did that thing and we
didn't know ah dude Thank thanks for
calling in to the podcast I thought I
thought people would have called no no
one the way I had it set up my my phones
aren't set up the correct way or because
I'm talking to you on FaceTime it's
blocking everything from working on that
I have two things hooked up my ipad with
the skype and my phone hooked up with
the Google Hangouts number and i have a
feeling something's blocking the other
or my wife eyes terrible who the [ __ ]
knows that's what's great about doing a
live podcast having a late time slot to
like we just kept going because it went
we went past the hour but that thanks
for doing the the pockets and and I
guess you would like to just plug your
podcast alright so the comedy film nerds
they could find that on all things
comedy calm I'm sure on I yes yeah
comedy film nerds calm itunes and
Twitter comedy film nerds and then my
personal twitter is chris j Mancini all
right Chris dude thank you so much for
for being on the podcast and if I
absolutely want to do yours when I come
out to LA you have an open invitation
Jonah was great catching up with you we
haven't talked in many years yeah tell
your wife I'll never forget those days
going up your steps yeah I will indeed
alright man see you take care jail
bye-bye foot come come tomorrow night to
the stress factory guys go to stress
factory commies want to buy tickets to
that live podcast will be doing it there
830 is the podcast time
live stand-up show starts at
seven-thirty buy the ticket to that and
you stay for both ha the stand-up shows
only for like 45 minutes long we go
right into the podcast should be a great
time new brunswick new jersey stress
factory dot-com what else should i plug
should i plug some dates why not come
and see me live everybody this saturday
i'll be in hasbrouck heights Hasbrouck
Heights New Jersey albeit bananas comedy
club that's februari 27 februari 11th
and 12th the dead crow comedy club in
Wilmington North Carolina and then may
eighteenth and nineteenth brand new club
called ha in Yonkers New York seven
minutes from my house inside the ridge
hill amazing high-end mall there took an
outdoor mall over there the Yonkers area
and then the 24th 25th and 26th of march
i'll be at laugh boston in boston
massachusetts as I end every podcast I
hope by me trying to fix me I help you
fix you a little bit love my wife I love
my kids and keep downloading these
podcasts everybody love you guys for
listening and one more time a shout out
to the man Larry may for those huge
donations it turned my trip into a way
better trip to Arizona okay thanks dude
I appreciate it [ __ ] come out
tomorrow night thursday
alright see you later have a great
you